welcome everybody nice to see everybody
here I'm kind of sad that this
conference actually might come to a
close so obviously I wasn't planning on
giving this talk so and it's been a
little over a month since I gave it and
I never give the same talk twice so I'm
feeling a little guilty but such as it
may how many people have used Jupiter
notebooks pretty much everybody is there
somebody in here that hasn't used
Jupiter notebooks
okay all right good good has anybody
used Jupiter hub other than Peter okay
you can put your hand up Peter
okay so much smaller group great so you
guys are gonna keep answer all the hard
questions should they come up okay so
basically the concept behind this
presentation is I I'm kind of nerdy and
I like this thing explainer book that
the xkcd guy wrote and I thought okay
mins got this great tutorial he did it
high data London about Jupiter hub but
it's not really a beginner's or an
introduction to Jupiter hub it's really
like okay you're gonna deploy Jupiter
hub ready set go
but it's great and I highly recommend
seeing it so this is more the concept of
how to do Jupiter hub in thousand common
words or so and make it so that you can
understand the underlying architecture
of Jupiter hub which would then make it
easier to go through mins tutorial and
actually deploy it on your own so this
presentation is as I said the
user-friendly introduction to Jupiter
hub it's not a deep dive it's not a
workshop though I will give you links to
mins talk and the tutorial that we
crafted around it and I will go back
actually all these slides are on a bitly
link
at Jupiter hub - PDC so you don't have
to worry about scribbling furiously to
get it things down who's it for pretty
much anybody but primarily scientists
engineers researchers people running
user groups and again it's just to make
it easier to deploy Jupiter hub and try
it out and play around with it okay so
Jupiter hub is essentially a way to give
a jupiter notebook server to a number of
people in a group so you get a jupiter
hub single notebook server you get a
jupiter notebook server and so on for
those of you that haven't worked with
the notebook the notebook is a couple of
things on one level it's a document that
you can share back and forth where you
can annotate and remix code video
podcast audio and visualizations talk to
this guy about visualizations and on
another level it's an environment an
interactive environment in which you can
write code run code and on the final
level it's a web application and by that
I mean the user interface part is
running in a browser which is
communicating a real WebSocket to a
server running on your computer or
somewhere else so if we look at it from
the architecture of just a single user
notebook you have the browser where
you're entering in stuff and seeing
stuff you've got the Jupiter notebook
server which is basically handling
getting the information in passing it
off to the different language kernels
for the kernels to do their work
taking it back and spitting it back to
the user so think of the kernels as not
the traditional like UNIX kernels but
simply smart little language things that
process in their own particular language
and when we as part of the Jupiter team
refer to a single user notebook server
we're talking about the notebook server
and the kernels that you have installed
and we will kind of for the rest of the
presentation use the little Jupiter
symbol to symbolize this single user
notebook server and so Jupiter hub like
we said before has the ability to give a
notebook server to each person in the
group so how does that work well the hub
which is in the bottom left hand corner
manages authentication of users it is
responsible for spawning these different
single user notebook servers that will
go to each individual user and it gives
the users their complete notebook server
and access to it over on the right hand
side is the actual notebook server which
may or may not be running on the same
system as the hub but for the purposes
of conceptualizing it they are two
distinct things the server's notebook
servers and the hub are different and
then there's a proxy that acts as the
crossing guard or Gateway if you will
for routing information to the hub or to
the single user notebook server
depending on what you're doing at any
given moment so the hub is made up of a
user database an Authenticator and a
spawner
the users and their individual notebook
servers are part of what we call Jupiter
hub and the proxy the proxy is main job
is to route like if we do okay localhost
well not localhost but some URL slash
hub it will typically be an
administrative command so we're going to
route it directly to the hub if it is a
user we're going to route it to the user
and then depending on whether it's your
first communication with the single
notebook server for a user or a later
communication it will authenticate you
with the hub using the API and then get
a response and store some sort of cookie
on your local work on your individual
notebook server user database place to
keep information about the people using
Jupiter hub the authenticators are a
combination of things it could be Pam it
could be a auth so there are different
authentication modes that people have
written some of the Jupiter team has
written some of them are people in the
community that have written them and it
really is whether or not a user has the
ability to access a notebook server and
the spawner to then spawn the notebook
server
I don't have my clicker today and then
the spawner is basically the worker bee
that's sitting there and as it gets
requests from the hub other components
it will go out and it will say okay I'm
going to spin up a little single user
notebook server here another single user
notebook server there another one for
you over here and those could be in
docker containers they could be on the
same physical system that you're on it
could be on a different system so
there's different spawners with
different parameters and putting it all
together
you've kind of got the conceptual view
on the right-hand side and mins more
block diagram on the left-hand side so
in this case when we've got a group of 6
users we're gonna have six individual
notebook servers and each one will have
their own and each one will have a URL
that they access their notebook server
with so when would we want to use
Jupiter hub well it could be used in a
class where you have students that are
doing homework and you might combine it
with something like env grader which
does some automated grading of student
assignments so basically you want to
ensure that the students have a baseline
system with which to work and they're
all working with the same dependencies
and things and you don't want to
necessarily have them install every
single package if they're perhaps not
technically savvy so things like you
might be teaching a GIS class but it's
more to geography students who aren't
computer scientists to have them Khanda
install or pip install gets to be kind
of burdensome for the TAS and the
professors so Jupiter hub is a good
alternative there if you're doing a
short-lived workshop an installation is
particularly annoying or hard
maybe you have to build different
dependencies and C or something you
could use psychic build which would be
an excellent option and you should check
it out and but it simplifies having to
have every person running when you're
running a workshop have to build their
own configuration and you wind up with
somebody's laptop that's like ancient
and somebody else's whose is brand-new
and running beta version of whatever it
simplifies that sometimes you just
simply have a research group and a small
cluster and you just want to be able to
share notebooks files database resources
whatever with that small group and that
makes sense or if you want to use some
on-site computing resources within an
institution that you want to give access
to and you know in a sort of sort of a
streamlined way when would we not want
to use Jupiter hub remember Jupiter hub
is authenticated and persistent so if we
want to just spin up a notebook and we
don't care if it goes away after we're
done with the session then maybe Jupiter
hubs not what you need maybe it's
something like temp n B that you can
create anonymous notebooks and they go
away binder is another project it's not
one that project Jupiter manages but we
do have people that contribute to it
binder is actually temp MB that you can
take a github repo upload it and then
people can use the notebook
interactively and it's really a nice
thing and Jeremy Freeman and the whole
group that works on finder has done a
great job and then sage math cloud is a
good option if you want a hosted service
that also enables real-time
collaboration over
individual notebook as far as where
would you find more resources if you
wanted to try out Jupiter hub we have a
couple of reference deployments one is
using docker and I think Peter probably
could answer some of the questions on it
and another one is using no docker
because what we found was some of the
professors that were setting it up for
their class didn't feel as comfortable
with docker or couldn't use it in their
environment so it's a you can deploy it
with a bunch of ansible strip scripts on
a bare metal server again mins pilot
data London talk is fabulous and I
highly encourage you to take a look at
it we've also got a repo associated with
it so there is configuration scripts and
things that let you configure it in
several different ways that coordinate
with the tutorial and in July we did a
mini workshop it was sort of HPC
oriented so high performance computing
oriented but we had different members of
our community speak for about 15 minutes
each on how they were using it what they
wanted changed what they wanted added
and all of that is in a repo with
markdown files PDFs and and the video
source as well so in addition we have
some documentation on Jupiter hub and
for those of you that have been
following Jupiter for a while several
months ago we split out from the Jupiter
organization because we started having a
ton of repos and it was really hard to
kind of keep track of everything we put
Jupiter hub in its own organization so
all the Jupiter hub resources will be
under the Jupiter hub organization
and that's all I had for the formal
Jupiter hub presentation I did tack on
the end a little Jupiter lab preview
who's heard of Jupiter lab okay much
less okay cool
Jupiter lab is actually the next
generation notebook if you will
there was a great video on it that was
done at SCI PI 2016 by Jason grout and
Bryan Granger and I don't know if Steve
and Sylvester talked did you talked no
and well worth doing what it does is it
gives you multiple windows and there is
a actually I'll pull up the why can't I
grab my screen so much for my
presentation now you can read my email
there's nothing exciting if you want to
answer it I'd be abundantly happy so at
this point I kind of would be willing to
just throw it open to any kind of
Jupiter question whether it's Jupiter
notebook Jupiter lab Jupiter hub and
invite Peter and Thomas and others to
jump in as they feel yeah
FPL we're using jupiter hub to do to
provide notebooks to the scientists to
work with and we have it built up so
that the jupiter hub and the vigils in
the individual servers run on one
machine and then the kernels actually
run on a remote machines which are owned
by the particular beamlines so you can
split the where the compute happens
first where all the management happens
very nicely good thanks works did you
install it or no damn okay yes yes so uh
let's say we have a group of people and
ten fifteen people and obviously I would
like to have my own note do you play
with things and research but then I may
have may want to have a notebook that I
share with three four or five people
share I mean we make take we may need to
take turns to to work on a notebook
right so I login they look in right we
just have to create like a user ID
ensure the israelian password
any maybe any work that sort of plans to
address that okay so there are plans
down the road there's no timeframe on it
yet to do real-time collaborative
editing of notebooks saved mouth cloud
has it now as far as I understand what
you what we typically see people doing
now because we don't have that
capability is they will work on a
notebook they will check it into source
control somebody else will check it out
check in their changes so it's it's
iterative it's not a real-time
collaboration if you will but it tends
to work actually fairly well we do have
a new project that folks have been
working on called NB dime which allows
you to do dipping of notebooks or
merging notebooks which was something
that the community really wanted and I
think makes it a lot easier to do
notebooks and under version control
and particularly before github started
rendering notebooks it was really hard
to know what was in a notebook until you
actually loaded it up so that will also
help so I don't that's probably the best
I can do with your question a round of
applause for our amazing in front